social media companies could soon be in
big trouble over how addictive their
platforms have become a new California
bill would hold companies legally
responsible and prohibit them from using
features and algorithms that get kids 18
and younger hooked on their products
Tech Titans would be liable if children
develop an eating disorder receive
information related to buying drugs
Firearms or Dying by Suicide and could
face penalties of up to 250 thousand
dollars for each violation
all right before we get to the
legalities Jesse what do you think about
this for
just Innovation capitalism protecting
kids well in terms of innovation and
capitalism I think it's pretty bad you
can't turn social media companies into
tobacco companies and just say you can't
advertise well to anybody under 18.
here's my solution I just would like if
you're a minor or even maybe 16 you just
have to prove how old you are before you
log on a lot of these Tech Titans don't
even let their own children on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter why do you think
that is it's because this stuff is sick
and it rewires your brain but it's also
the parents have become lazy they're
basically saying why don't we let the
rest of society parent my own children
I'm not a good enough parent to make
sure my kid doesn't stare at the stupid
screen all day I'm not a good enough
parent to maybe check inside My Kid's
Closet to see if there's not an AR-15
you can't blame everybody else for your
own child's ridiculous behavior and
that's what this is and it's poorly
written so if your kid has an eating
disorder you can sue YouTube I don't
know if that's going to hold up in court
but what do you think would it hold up
in court
very very difficult to prove causation
and it really sounds to me that they're
trying to substitute good parenting for
uh you know uh these laws it's uh but do
your parents need help but if you could
sue of course but uh if you could sue
Tick Tock why can't you sue an alcohol
company or a gun company
specifically prohibited in terms of guns
judges you know uh I I think that you
can't start messing around you're trying
to deal with something that is having a
detrimental effect on your particular
children
you can't do it with legislation you've
got to do it with Ma and Pa they got to
talk to the kid your view judge
you know first of all all the sample
legislation that I've seen here makes it
a prosecutable offense where an attorney
general or a prosecutor comes in it
doesn't give a parent the right to
litigate although they talk about Mass
actions as opposed to class actions
um this is a continuing effort on to
kind of curb social media and some of
these platforms they tried it with a
section 230 and it didn't work and you
know they kind of slipped away and so
now what they're trying to do is they're
trying to say that these media companies
are responsible for you know addicting
and uh for for causing kids to commit
suicide the causation issue as you say
is the ultimate issue how do you prove
that that your child killed himself or
herself because of social media bullying
or whatever and then you get to the
question of subjectivity how do you
assess subjectivity how do I say that my
child was better before and then
depressed after I mean there are all
these issues but but you know as a
parent I would like it one way as a
prosecutor I know that it's almost
impossible to prove causation but let me
just say uh one more thing about this
addiction you know it's like gambling is
an addiction you don't sue a casino
because your kid is gambling whether
it's online or in a casino online
gambling and teenagers are doing this I
know from when I was D.A and you know so
you shouldn't necessarily be able to sue
these companies for addictions so the
problem is the parents are relinquishing
their roles as caretakers and turning
these things into babysitters and you
know what they're suffering the
consequences and I I feel badly for them
but I had certain roles uh rules for my
kids and I think parents should too
Greg rules for kids yeah you know uh I'm
addicted to social media but I'm an
adult so I can make these choices you
know I think that you need to control it
for kids consumption I noticed in that
list they made of the things that were
harmful that could be caused by social
media they left out gender affirmation
surgery and I look at that and I go is
it any wonder the rise in non-binary
identification and trans militism has
accompanied the flourishing of tick tock
so I'm thinking I think you guys are
right you can't sue a platform but can
you sue somebody promoting a damaging
Behavior somebody that goes on there and
says I want you're going to eat 20 Tide
Pods where everybody eat 20 Tide Pods or
somebody goes on there and says you know
what you should start binding your
breasts you're not happy being a girl
and you know what you should get those
breasts removed that's the person the
person that that that pushes out and
promotes the content creator the content
creator but I don't know so the question
is is it foreseeable that that if you
promote this that someone is going to do
it and can they at this end prove the
causation that should have been
foreseeable in order in order to have a
loss step closer to the producer the the
actual principle suing the principle
would be a lot closer than I think I'll
just say one thing one of the problems
that those with the content creator is
with the algorithm right so you have one
content creator it's let's say I watch
one video but then because the algorithm
will say well now if you like that
you'll like this and that's what these
I guess well-intentioned people are
trying to do which is to say we need to
stop pushing all the content to somebody
we had a young girl that was on
America's Newsroom who says she became
uh anorexic after having all of these
videos sent to her and making her feel
like that uh tough issues but ask
yourself the question what about you
know some of these magazines I agree no
I agree I know I know I never did you
could have said that 20 years ago right
yeah like right all those and what about
child stars what about child stars we
have to protect their ability to make
money for the parents you know what we
need a second hour of the five
he's exhausting all right much more to
come on the five hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else